[Applause]
a lot of goosebumps and a ton of emotion
pouring out from many of us who love
this country so much
glad you're with us on this saturday
night we will continue to honor those
throughout our entire broadcast here
tonight casey mize gets the nod tonight
he's making his 27th start of the season
his first career start against tampa so
i'm sure he's looking forward to that
brings him up
casey mises first strikeout of the night
called third on joy and an easy first
inning for casey mize head to the bottom
of the first inning in detroit scoreless
right-hander chris archer that last
outing five innings 78 pitches season
highs
i mean not at all
that's into left center where kirmeyer
is camped out and kiermaier is able to
go over and get a heck with kiermeier
out there in his range it's almost like
a five-man outfield we're done with one
in detroit racing tigers are scoreless
so the rays have the first scoring
opportunity mike zenino now with wendell
at third
ground ball third windows headed to the
plate he is safe at the plate
haas thought they had him and of course
the rays
if they have a runner at third and
there's contact
more times than not they're headed to
the plate i mean way more times than not
that was a close play and the tigers
want to take a look at it
and he is the raise
get the first run of the night
zanino picks up the run batted in his
56th
fly ball left center field and that ball
is going to drop in there and roll to
the wall picked up by grossman
zenino is digging for the plate he will
score standing
and the rays have a two nothing lead in
the left-center and kiramara winds up at
third with the rays now leading
two-nothing i'll tell you the way that
the rays run the base pass can you
imagine if this is their home field oh
my goodness
it's
they get out of the box and they they
want to take that extra base at all
times
great job by kier meyer the extension
driving that ball zanino knows kier
meyer is going to third so that means he
better make it home he does so wendell
and zanino have scored the runs first
and third and one out it's two nothing
rays looking for more and here's brandon
lau
that's the other way into left
grossman is there to make the catch tag
and kiermeier
will score
walls remains at first and the rays pick
up
another run
it's a three-run inning
lao
collecting his 83rd run batted in
upright stands hands are tight by the
left shoulder as he [ __ ] the bat over
it 3-2 swinging a fly ball left field
deep on the run grossman tracking it
he'll make the catch
running to the left field corner
long inning for casey my seven men to
the plate a lot of pitches thrown
meadows finally flies out to ending
pitch and change brian garcia takes over
for casey mize mine's just two innings
of work three runs three hits a couple
of strikeouts 48 pitches for casey mize
rosarina ground ball up the middle
backhanded by willy castro from shallow
left throws to first and he got him fine
play
willy castro ended up way over in shadow
left field
range far to his right got a lot on the
throw the best play we've seen him make
all year you talk about the art of
fielding there it was as good as you
will see at the big leagues joey wendell
at the plate
that's a well tagged ball into deep
right center reyes will turn around and
watch it sail
home run for joey wendell his tenth of
the year
joey wendell now with a triple and a
home run and boy did he
lay into that one
four-nothing
rays i'll tell you what when the sound
of the crack at the back is that crisp
through the tv that's all you need to
know about the contact changeup gets
laid out right out over the plate
and joey wendell didn't miss brandon
today has a run batted in on a sacrifice
fly to left field
now a base hit into center field
that will get kermeyer home
a run batted in for lau the round is
charged to garcia and the ray's building
now a five-run lead second rbi of the
game for laos well we talked in the
opener we at some point yesterday during
the game we were talking about brandon
lau and his turnaround against
left-handed pitching he got a hanging
breaking ball right there by kroll but
doing a much better job of keeping that
front size close front side closed
staying in on these lefties and the
numbers have really jumped in the last
couple of months
somehow someway tigers just need to
start things rolling get on the board
right here's miguel cabrera who grounded
to short his first time on
right field and that's a base hit
an rbi single for miguel cabrera
he gets the tigers on the board on a
saturday night in detroit we've all
grown to really love what miggy can do
with runners
at third base he does not try to do too
much he just wants to make a good swing
this is a
slider on the outer half and he goes
right with the pitch lines it out to
right field scope just jogs in easily
cabrera now 26 hits away from 3 000 as
they change the mighty milestone in left
center field 5-1 rays looking to have an
answer after the tigers got one in the
fourth
there's a shot
back into deep center field madue runs
it down and makes the catch
and now the rays tack on another run
chris archer was actually taken out of
the game due to left hip discomfort rays
will have a new pitcher as we move into
the bottom of the fifth inning they have
built a 6-1 lead inns will make his
sixth appearance in a raised uniform the
one-two pitcher bends swinging at a miss
he struck him out and there's one going
here in the fifth so and strikes out
good trim to begin the fifth inning ends
throws struck him out swinging with a
high fastball at 95. and as it turns out
the errors cost him a few pitches but
nothing more and at the end of five it
is detroit trailing the race there's
an opportunity to add to this advantage
and a fly ball the dew and center will
make the catch
the tag and walls heads to the plate
with another raised run that will make
it seven to one robbie grossman hasn't
struck out at all but he has flown out
three times he stands in with one away
in the ninth
slide ball deep right field they don't
have one there
no they don't it's gone and robbie
grossman with a solo bomb here in the
ninth number 23 on the year two out
nobody on the ninth here's candelario
and armstrong to the plate
and he got him a swing and a miss to end
this one so the rays are winners seven
to two the rays pull even in the series
they win their 89th game of the year